[Music]
when we did the the sound design of the
music was already there so basically the
music was the leader of the see there's
just something vibration of being
hypnotized the the music was clearly in
the mood of that and we had to increase
our element and all the sort of you know
like Alex after for instance when they
pass to the left and the plane to the
left house so they we cut the frequency
to have a certain kind of a moody dreamy
vibration to it and Delia Kaptur is also
really fluently changed rhythm it's how
we it started with a very clear rhythm
and then all of a sudden the recaptured
changed to a non rhythmical rhythm and
then it goes like this with radio and
transference and the bass was the music
and then all the work of putting the
helicopter in and then coming into the
bass slowly that was the the first color
to that scene and after that it's going
with the the the outside picture like
fantastic visual visual material then
you want it for the music to creep in
without us really noticing when it's
actually starting through the the sound
of the helicopter
so as we're as Louise is it's kind of
diving into realizing what is happening
there with all the crowd there is
completely crazy all the crowd and
there's we can hear a little bit of some
horns and even some some faint screaming
of people down there and horn car horns
that is just barely cutting through and
then we're diving into this land of
music helicopter sound and communication
there's also a little communication
devices of radio going back and forth
from the base to the helicopter and
there were all sorts of material that
were created but then the idea was to
blend all of this as like supremacy
like a dreamy thing
we're gonna take three bags I think your
cellphone's
follow me
sir these banks you not only last time
either of you of eating last night same
as last time you did something stressful
does now count just saying huh
who's being carted off in the medivac
not everyone is able to process
experiences like this I would like also
to talk about when we land because we
are lest we have this trippy mood but
when we land on the base the base the
military base to be chaotic with with
the helicopter jet a PA that say orders
soldiers that move around talk loud so
an appendage and and Lewis saw the
medevac that we will understand later on
that the mini-vac
scary the the first sentence is in fact
that I replace so she already arrived
after kind of moody vibe arrived this in
this unfamiliar land and where she does
not belong to the military world Lewis
is not comfortable with those people and
I think the message in a way is kind of
clear when she land there everything
you're doing here I have to explain to a
roomful of men whose first and last
question is how can this be used against
us kangaroo what is that in 1770 Captain
James Cook's ship ran aground off the
coast of Australia and he led a party
into the country in them at the
Aboriginal people one of the sailors
pointed at the animals that hop around
and put their babies in their pouch and
he asked what they were and the
aborigine said kangaroo it wasn't till
later that they learned that kangaroo
means I don't understand I can sell that
for now yeah and remember what happened
to the Aborigines a more advanced race
nearly wiped them out
it's a good story
Thanks it's not true but it proves my
point it's interesting it's about
language but they cannot relate with
vocal language they had to relate on
writing language because vocal language
is too complex to achieve so Louise as a
to do as a as a linguist had to
understand there to pass through their
writing instead of their vocals and I am
NOT a linguist but I I don't know if
it's it's an interesting path the fact
that you have to go to writing and and
throughout the film communication will
remain for her a conflict in fact that
she will carry something in her that she
cannot share she she have a hard time to
share and she will even later on in her
life will have a hard time to share what
their future husband will become the dad
of her daughter so I think it's it's an
interesting path the way how
communication is is a very uneasy thing
throughout the famous route maybe life
in general
then you really wanted us to feel the
huge size of those aliens and that their
physical big power and for that he just
wanted the to the alien for the aliens
to be as loud as they could and the
music also carries this huge power of
all I would say with those huge like
intense moments when we are going into
the ship
[Music]
but throughout all of this what Savannah
was talking about just earlier the the
human aspect of the film dictated a lot
of subtleties and and delicacy and so to
have to be always on on one side and the
other was was a challenging thing and
really really fun thing to to play with
because we like we love as some people
we love subtleties also and making
making things go through lightly and
then making a huge big statement
powerful statement with from the aliens
and going from one to the other really
matched the film having those big aliens
there and the the human aspect of this
character faced with so many things that
I hope we will never feel
now that's a proper introduction